[Musica]
avete mai pensato a come ci è stata
insegnata la storia sono di origine
greco egiziane sono nato e cresciuto a
cavallo di due culture di due mondi
ho passato metà della mia vita al cairo
e l'altra metà in italia e questa è
un'esperienza che mi ha plasmato
eppure quando penso alla storia
dell'incontro fra oriente e occidente
quello che mi viene in mente sono date
di battaglie memorie di massacri scenari
di guerra
gran parte della storia dell'arte è
influenzata da questa visione di guerra
pensate al mosaico è ritrovato a pompei
è esposto oggi al museo archeologico di
napoli dove è raffigurata la battaglia
disse con alessandro magno che sconfigge
dario di persia
oppure alla cosiddetta di via dei
crociati conservata alla morgan library
di new york
oppure al dipinto di antoine john room
che raffigura napoleone bonaparte mentre
a niente i mamelucchi egiziani davanti
alle piramidi all'esordio della campagna
d'egitto
esiste un altro modo di guardare alla
storia la risposta è sì attraverso la
creatività e la bellezza attraverso gli
oggetti che di esseri umani hanno creato
per l'uso quotidiano per adornarsi per
decorare le proprie abitazioni per
adorare le proprie divinità
e questo è esattamente quanto ha fatto
nel mag record storico dell'arte
direttore del british museum che nel
raccontò la storia del mondo in una
trasmissione radiofonica sulla bbc
attraverso 100 oggetti tratti dalla
collezione del museo
questa serie radiofonica ha dato origine
ad un libro di successo intitolato
appunto storia del mondo in 100 oggetti
ed è una modalità che il british museum
ha utilizzato per raccontare la storia
di altre civiltà come quella cinese o
quella islamica
potremmo fare un ulteriore passaggio e
non limitarsi a raccontare la storia
delle singole civiltà attraverso gli
oggetti ma la storia dell'umanità come
un lungo elenco di incontri di fusioni
in una specie di globalizzazione ante
litteram la risposta è sì e ve lo
dimostrerò in un viaggio virtuale in una
manciata di minuti in cui percorreremo
paesi culture continenti
in un arco temporale
tra la metà del quattrocento e la metà
del cinquecento l'epoca del rinascimento
quella di uomini visionari o se volete
super visionari
cominciamo da lui un uomo che ebbe
giovanissimo un sogno si dice nella
tradizione o forse una visione ed e
mehmet il conquistatore fate secondo la
tradizione ottomana colui che ha
espugnato costantinopoli l'abominevole
granturco che mise fine alla millenaria
storia dell'impero romano d'oriente
chi l'avrebbe mai immaginato che questo
stesso uomo
avrebbe posato per gentile bellini un
artista veneziano
per farsi ritrarre e che questo stesso
artista durante il suo soggiorno ad
istanbul avrebbe ritratto diversi
personaggi come questo turco in piedi
con il turbante i bozzetti di gentile
bellini avrebbero ispirato altri pittori
negli anni a venire e così lo stesso
personaggio che vediamo nei suoi
bozzetti
ricompare negli appartamenti borgia nel
vaticano e ricompare nel quadro dei tre
filosofi del giorgione un artista del
tardo rinascimento veneziano
venezia già forse la città più orientale
d'italia
guardate le cupole del duomo di san
marco e la merlatura di palazzo ducale
sono prese in prestito dalle moschee
mamme look del cairo un'altra città
frequentata dagli intrepidi mercanti
veneziani
non a caso sempre bellini quando ha
voluto raffigurare la predica di san
marco in santo vissuto ad alessandria
d'egitto
scelse di ambientarla in un panorama
costellato di cupole di minareti gli
obelischi e persino con delle giraffe
che passeggiano davanti al duomo di san
marco traslato nella
alessandria d'egitto voi state cercando
adesso dove la giraffa vero eccola qui
ma cosa ci fa una giraffa davanti al
duomo di san marco in realtà una giraffa
si era già materializzata in italia
esattamente nel 1487 dono del sultano
d'egitto a lorenzo il magnifico
un dono ad un uomo visionario ad un
grande mecenate
talmente visionario che tentò di
riprodurre in europa la preziosa
porcellana cinese
non ci riuscì pienamente però quel
nucleo di 80 oggetti che prendono il
nome di porcellane medicea sono una
testimonianza
di quanto vicino ci fosse arrivato
guardate queste porcellane le loro forme
i loro disegni sono chiaramente ispirati
dalla coeva produzione ceramica della
città di iznik l'antica nicea in turchia
piatti come quello che vedete con gli
stemmi occidentali erano fabbricati
appositamente in oriente per le famiglie
nobili europee facevano parte dei beni
di lusso di importazione come i grandi
vassoi metallici che provenivano dal
cairo i grandi vassoi di dei mamelucchi
fatti in ottone con delle grandi fasce
calligrafiche in lingua araba e che
hanno ispirato le aureole delle madonne
nei quadri rinascimentali dove possiamo
scorgere
proprio le pseudo calligrafia araba che
ritroviamo tra l'altro anche nelle
pieghe dei tessuti dei vestiti del david
del verrocchio una mirabile opera in
bronzo come gli automi gli automi secoli
prima venivano prodotti in oriente
affascinavano le corti occidentali e
dopo saranno le porti occidentali a
produrre ea mandarli in doni alle corti
orientali
non a caso ritroviamo diana il cervo
nelle mani di un attendente della corte
cinquecentesca dell'imperatore jahan
gere un imperatore della dinastia
musulmana dei mughal che per secoli ha
retto le sorti del subcontinente indiano
una dinastia
talmente
visionaria e talmente aperta e
tollerante
che nelle raffigurazioni della sala
delle udienze ritroviamo affreschi che
raffigurano cristo e la madonna in una
corte musulmana appunto una madonna che
ricompare anche in un ritratto custodito
gelosamente dal più grande e il più
visionario dei sovrani della dinastia
musulmana dei look al akhbar
abbiamo percorso assieme un viaggio
lungo centinaia di migliaia di
chilometri siamo passati dall italia
all'egitto alla turchia
abbiamo
toccato alla cina ma ognuno di quegli
oggetti
ognuna di quelle miniature avrebbe
potuto darci degli spunti per andare
oltre
arrivare in portogallo andare nelle
americhe
ritornare di nuovo in medio oriente poi
andare di nuovo in india in cina
forse il caso quindi
imparare e soprattutto rendersi conto
che la storia dell'umanità non è solo
una storia di scontri ma anche di
incontri grazie
[Applauso]